if you have a problem with
procrastination and you are just not
getting the stuff done that needs to get
done then this video is for you
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe if I believe in you
I want to see this big idea that you
have inside you actually come out
actually start to make an impact for
yourself your family your community in
the world and one of the biggest
problems that I see with entrepreneurs
is they procrastinate you have ideas but
you don't actually do anything about it
and then time runs out and you miss your
window and so today I'm going to talk
about the seven ways that you can stop
procrastinating and make today your day
way number one is accept responsibility
this is what I think to be the most
important when you accept responsibility
for where you are in life that's when
things start to change so many people
entrepreneurs and otherwise are always
in the blaming and complaining game
you're not more successful because of
whatever your parents the government the
education system the country you live in
you know your gender your your
upbringing your background whatever it
is is a reason if you go to the mirror
and you ask yourself why am I not more
successful that answer that comes back
at you almost always for most people is
some kind of excuse some kind of
complaint some kind of putting the blame
on somebody else and listen a lot of
that is legit like if you did not grow
up like I grew up in Canada that's a
huge advantage if I'm not from Canada
it's harder to get started great but so
what like if you don't grow up in Canada
I mean you can't have success tons of
people have done it the people who you
look up to we've had massive success
have done it with less resources that
you already have right now the fact that
you are watching this video then you
have an internet connection then you're
investing time when yourself already
puts you ahead of most of the world and
so just accepting responsibility for
where you're at the reason why you are
here is because of you the reason that
your path is not more clear
is not taking off like you wanted to is
because of you and yes there's lots of
other factors that play a role but you
can't blame them
you gotta blame yourself you're gonna
take responsibility you're gonna start
taking some action but where you want in
life and when you first do that at the
start it sucks you know no there's
nobody else to blame wow that that
really hurts
like we could be depressing to realize
that everything is on you and there's
nobody coming to save you but I find it
also empowering like once you get
through the depression and the sadness
it's empowering it's like it's on me
it also means I can go and fix it I can
go and solve it I can go create a better
life for myself I don't need to wait for
a new president or for a new tax cut or
for a new whatever to come out I can do
this right now it's on me
if I put an energy hustle and dry I can
go make whatever I want happen when you
take on that life that's when things
start to change you need to accept
responsibility for where you are in life
and where you're going
we're number two is find your one word I
wrote a book it's called your one word
it's really about finding the most
important core value what you stand for
is a human being and then bringing that
to your life into your business
a lot of times why people procrastinate
and they stop doing something that
they're you know they say they're
excited by is that they don't really
know where they want to go they don't
really feel invigorated by their goal
their goal is too small or it's too
ambiguous or there's too many fears that
they have when you figure out what you
stand for when you figure out what your
one word is that should be a bold
empowering goal it should be a mission
that gets you excited on a regular basis
so for me it's about believe the content
indicas but believe my environment is
about believe my morning tea my habits I
both believe understanding what I stand
for allows me to create that more
positive routine and environment for
myself and gets me excited by the goal
that I'm chasing right I want to have an
impact on the world I want to make a big
difference when you are excited by your
goals you much more likely to do
something when you are not excited when
they're boring goals when is they'll
kind of behind them you're likely just
to put it off like I'll do that later or
I'll do that
or I can't do that when you were fired
up like this is important when I'm
making these videos for you I'm just
talking to a camera right now but I feel
the vibe I feel the importance that it's
like reaching through and touching you
guys that gets me excited to want to get
up and make these videos how do I make
three videos a day on my channel most
people have a hard time making a video a
week and I'm doing three a day why
because I love what I'm doing because I
have a big goal to want to change the
world
and so when you are excited by your
goals and that really comes from the
self-awareness to figure out what your
one word is what you stand for it gives
you the energy that fuel the motivation
to crash through the procrastination so
that you want to take action way number
three is create an action plan so having
an action plan is super important you
know it's great to have self-awareness
to understand what you want where it is
it's great to you know accept
responsibility for your life but now
what are you gonna do what's the goal
like what are the steps that you're
going to take this is where Marlin
success can work when you you find
people who've done what you want to do
you look up to
Steve Jobs at Howard Schultz or whoever
it is that you look up to look at what
made them successful a lot of people get
paralyzed by what to do next to get
paralyzed by the next step whatever how
do I do this thing what what am I
supposed to do and the next step doesn't
matter even that much it's not about
taking the first perfect step getting
over that fear there is no perfect next
step it's just continuing to build let's
let you do something and you do
something again the next day you do
something again the next day and for me
what really helped was just studying
successful people people who are inside
my industry who I could model from and
people were outside my industry that we
have may bring a different kind of vibe
or a different idea that I could apply
so I got some ideas that I could go up
and do I started building my action plan
so you build a plan don't spend a year
building an action plan research build a
plan and then start to do when you have
a plan that you know how to work for
other people when you model someone like
Steve Jobs or whoever's it you look up
to you say this worked for that person
at least for me I find that motivating
and it gives me the confidence to go
forward and start to do something and
stop the procrastination and take action
on that one
tip number four is to raise your stakes
the reason why you're progressing is
probably because you think the toss that
you'd have on hand is not that important
that's why you keep putting it off
another day another day over and over
and over again and it's just not a good
time now what if I told you that you are
a hostage negotiator
and there's a group of people that are
being held hostage right now and their
lives depend on you and it is your job
to free them and your job is to finish
that task so if you were to finish that
task means that this group of hostages
are going to be led out to the world
they're gonna go see their family
they're going to go back and contribute
back to the society but if you don't do
that task they will all die what would a
hostage negotiator do it was like oh man
oops sorry you didn't work out of course
not they will never ever say that they
will do whatever they can to free those
hostages right so you're going thinking
this is crazy Lily this is very extreme
like hostage negotiator versus me doing
an email that is a little bit too much
of a far-fetched and it's not that
important but I'm here to tell you that
it is not important because in a way
your idea your mission the thing that
you really want to do is being held
hostage and it is your job to release it
to the world so for example if you want
to be a fitness instructor and your
dream is to motivate
millions of people to work out and to
end obesity and that's your mission but
you are procrastinating sending the
first email to a client that you want to
train you're holding that ideal hostage
by not sending out that email to your
first client for whatever reason maybe
of a fear of rejection or maybe you
think is not that important as a result
people are going to die of obesity
because that email is going to lead you
to becoming the fitness instructor for
millions of people now you're never
going to be that person now people are
not going to be able to workout people
are not gonna be well people are not
gonna enjoy their lives once again
people are going to die because of that
now how does that feel how important
doesn't email feel to you there you go
it's always about raising the importance
of the thing that you're doing even
though you don't see the connection yet
I promise you there is a connection
make sure you see it make sure you make
it important so important that you
cannot do anything but that task at that
moment so next time you find yourself
procrastinating put yourself in the
shoes of a hostage negotiator and raise
your stakes
wait number 5 is improve your
environment your environment matters
where you work matters you know this is
my office why are these people up on the
wall that mean nothing to you some of
them you probably have no idea who they
are but I walk in and I get inspired I
wear this like this means something to
me talk to you like a superhero putting
on my hoodie and getting the work or the
t-shirt that I have on underneath you
know the environment that you're in
makes a difference and so think about
your environment think about the people
that you surround yourself with think
about where you're trying to come up
with your creative ideas there was a
great story by Sylvester Stallone who
said he used to block out all his
windows and work at night and I think
who was Nick Edgar Allen Poe did that
and so he modeled it from him but then
he found that all of his his writing was
really dark injury and miserable and
everybody was dying okay I need to
change that anything I need to work
enough in a brighter environment so
there's some positivity coming out too
now your environment has such a direct
influence over how you act how you
believe whether you take bold bets or
not it's so super important that you
start the
think about that consciously the people
who you around do they build you out do
they make you feel unstoppable do you
think if you power and motivation or do
they tell you you can't do that you're
never gonna be successful that's never
gonna work out for you the books that
you read are they inspiring right like I
read this every day
are they inspiring you know do they do
they help you lift up the videos that
you watch that is so important to help
in shape your actions and so if you
don't have good people in your life then
you can go work on eliminating some with
others right even if there's a boy even
if you don't fill them with somebody
else it's better than having a bunch of
negative people in your life so I look
at one the people that you're
surrounding yourself with do they help
build you up and then to your physical
environment from what's on the walls to
what you're wearing to you know what
what you're walking into
every day when you're trying to build
your business and changing that so it's
support you to actually take action when
number six is fix your habits I talked
about a little bit in the last point
every morning I wake up and I have a
morning routine that is empowering to me
and serves me so every morning I wake up
and I've got these birds that sing I
want to wake up to big birds in nature
more than like a blaring alarm clock I
wake up ten minutes before sunrise to
the birds I go to the washroom and I
read a page from the book there's two
genius ideas from legendary
entrepreneurs I drink a big glass of
water and then I write down my goals for
the day and I do this because it's so
easy to follow your day and and just
Coast just do the same thing you did
yesterday and or fall back down to the
expectations other people have for you
instead of pushing through and say like
I want to do something bold it's so easy
to procrastinate and do nothing and
slack off especially an entrepreneur who
doesn't have a boss on them saying you
need to do this right we are our own
bosses so we let ourselves down way too
much when I read a page from the book or
when I watch my youtube videos I do it
for me like I wrote the book that's
great that you guys picked it up and
read it it's great that you know you
watch the videos that I make I do it for
you but I don't mean like I need to
raise myself up I want to be around
success every single day if I open up
the book and I see a page from Steve
Jobs and there's too much Andheri ideas
from Piemonte there
I'm reading them it just makes me want
to do something bigger and I think it's
important to start your day with that
every single day and so whether it's
watching a video reading a book or
whatever the thing is for you you have
had moments in your life where you have
felt bold unstoppable ready to go up and
conquer believe in yourself
to a crazy degree kind of reverse
engineer that to think about what led to
that what was I doing that got me so
inspired and excited and animated what
was i doing and then put that into your
morning routine so that you're doing
that every single morning if you start
your day in a powerful way feeling bold
and unstoppable every single day your
life will be so different one year from
today and so I encourage you to figure
out what that thing is again tell me
it's the videos for me it's reading the
pages of the book to find out that thing
for you
put it into your daily routine and
you'll see a big change in your actions
and way number seven is build in
accountability
you know we're likely to let ourselves
down more than anybody else it's so easy
to you know set an alarm clock and then
hit that snooze button and the first
thing you did was you set a goal for
yourself and you let yourself down you
set a go along and wake up this time
snooze I'm just I'm saying it's okay not
that follow through my goals first thing
you do every day is agree to not go
through one the goals that you set for
yourself when we commit to somebody else
so much more likely to follow through
you know if you are going to go to the
gym with a buddy or a friend you're much
more likely to actually show up to do it
if you have a writing assignment you
know you want to you want to write
something for your website and you're
meeting up with somebody who wants to do
something for their website to say I'm
gonna meet you at two o'clock at
Starbucks and we're gonna grind this out
together you're much more likely to show
up and do the work because you committed
somebody else it was just you you're
less likely to follow foo and so it's
figuring out how can you build in some
accountability into your life whether
it's through a mastermind group whether
it's through a coach I have a mastermind
group in my business I have two one that
I run and one that I'm a part of on the
YouTube side I also find that the videos
hold me accountable you know when I
watch someone like Steve Jobs doing big
things it makes me feel like I had to do
more I gotta push harder right not in
the bad way not like I
can never be like Steve Jobs Who am I on
this small person more of a push forward
to say I can do more I can be bigger I
can I can follow through and so figuring
out whether it's a friend whether it's a
family member whether it's another
entrepreneur finding some way to be able
to hold yourself accountable to set
goals whether it's a weekly thing or
monthly thing like find somebody in your
network who you can come up with three
monthly goals for here are my goals the
next one through the three things that I
want to have happen what are your goals
are next month and then you have a quick
meeting at a coffee shop where you have
a quick call every Wednesday at 3
o'clock for 10 minutes - hey how you
doing on your goals well here's how I'm
doing how are you doing on your goals
just knowing that you have to talk to
somebody on Wednesday afternoon 3
o'clock and you have to update your your
goals see how you're doing you don't
want to get on that call and say I did
nothing just the pressure of having to
get on my call and talk to somebody will
make you do work on your business will
make you do work on the thing that you
say are important to you your goals and
so having some kind of accountability
again through a friend a buddy
mastermind coach something so that you
are not just doing it for you that
you're committed to other people means
you're much more likely to follow
through so thank you guys so much for
watching those are my seven ways and
stop procrastinating and make today your
day I made this video because Ken Neifi
asked me to and there's a topic you'd
like me to cover in a future seven ways
video check out the link in the
description go and cast your vote and I
might just do it for you I also love to
know which of the seven ways meant the
most to you had the biggest impact we're
gonna apply it somehow to your life or
your business or is there an eight
nineteen that you wanna add to the list
leave it down in the comments share some
love of belief nation I would love to
hear from you thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your language is much love I'll
see you soon
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that
man not one drop of myself work depends
on your it's something Sammy
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details